we have a couple write-in candidates for
great show moments yeah there was a
moment when Reggie Miller our good buddy
tackled mclovin in Los Angeles to do
they went over the top of the chair a
lot of people like that one and and I
just worried that somebody's going to
get hurt but reg came out and I just
remember he tackled mclovin been they
both went over the chair great great
visual there Reggie Reggie joins us now
he will be calling lakers at my lakers
at the kings coming up thursday night at
ten thirty eastern on tnt reg how are
you well that flashback moment of me
taking out mclovin was kind of like the
Richard Sherman hit last night on this a
little bit you know I saw a wide open
shot and I went in and I took it
basically in the story but that's the
way you played your career you saw a
wide open shot you took it exactly give
me the ball if it's wide open i'm going
to shoot and I would say eighty five
percent I'm going to make it if I'm wide
open I I thought of you last night when
steph curry hit 13 threes in a game and
i was wondering because it's donyell
marshall and Kobe who were tied with
staff with the old record and I said to
Paulie on I don't know how many reg had
did he get to double digits and what
would you find out Paulie I don't think
I've ever got the double digit I think
nine did you Reggie had eight twice ate
twice in a game I'm so disappointed in
myself yeah but I am so disappointed in
myself Theodore yeah but if you were
playing now and if Ray played now or
Larry played now because rare larry was
probably shooting one or two threes a
game back then because it just wasn't
part of anybody's game plan you know let
me say this to the three very prevalent
in today's game but let's give Steph and
korver and clay and all the great
shooters Damian Lillard let's give them
all the credit for making them because
it's easy for us to go back and say well
if Ray of myself if Dale Ellis if we
played in today's generation we would be
smattering these records as well I want
to give credit to those guys because
it's easy for us you know for me to try
to feel Steph shoes
would it be nice to play in today's era
yes I played it to me in the golden era
so I'm happy about that but I am NOT
going to hate on a guy knocking down 13
threes I mean I was shaking my head
watching the game I just kept shaking my
head like this is video game this is
really video game but it was a reminder
game for me reg because we haven't seen
anything from Steph Curry this year
hadn't been over 30 he went 0 for 10
from three-point range against my lakers
Durant's leading the team in scoring it
was one of those oh that's right Steph
Curry's still the best shooter in the
game and I think people tend to forget
that because you know obviously the
headlines are with the signing of kevin
durand and you know obviously coming
with it and i think i said this on this
show that they were going to have to
separate who was going to be the alpha
male and I said even before the season
Kevin Durant is your best player so out
of those two players something was going
to have to give and we've seen early on
and if you're Steve Kerr in the coaching
staff and I know everyone thinks the sky
is falling up in the Bay Area I mean
we're only seven eight games into them
people and it's going to take a while
for them to figure out that pecking
order and that chemistry because it does
take a lot it is going to take some time
for them to find that and between those
two players of curry and Durant they
were going to have to find that pecking
order and I think it's starting to
manifest a little bit reg calls the
lakers at the kings coming up thursday
night on TNT I what are we seeing from
the Lakers now that you think is
actually going to play out the rest of
the season number one I will give Luke
Walton all the credit because living out
here after every single Laker loss he
holds those young guys accountable and
that is the hardest thing to coach and
teach in the Association because most
young players in most young teams it's
hard for them to fathom okay we got to
move on to the next play most young
players and teams they like you know the
folk they like to get upset they can't
move on and go to the next play Luke has
done a great job of holding them
accountable and having them being able
to see the next play
and that's very difficult for a young
team they're gonna still take their
lumps but they play hard I I thought
that if it wasn't for them seems like
Lou Williams having those trends to help
buddy Angela on the julius fantastic
fantastic locker room it's just a great
mixture they play hard before the last
two years they've rolled over and played
dead the Lakers I'm sorry I hate to say
that even with Kobe they rolled over and
play dead this year you're gonna have to
beat the laker they're gonna play hard
each and every night yeah I like what
I've seen and I like tempo and I said if
I'm a Laker fan at least I'm seeing
something in the embryonic stages that
might grow into something that's really
fun you know the maybe one of the best
things that happen is Randall you know
broke his leg and you know got hurt and
that allowed him to get Ingram in there
to add a little more depth not that you
would want that to happen to a good
player but even Randall is sort of
developed into a draymond Green type for
them and now they're there I think
they're close to being an entertaining
team on a nightly basis and i think you
know Luke understanding that with that
because you can't get go let a we're
going to do golden state system you
can't do golden state system but I think
you can the personnel yeah you can take
off you can make a hybrid of golden
state system and you know use portions
of it and feels like Luke's trying to do
that with the Lakers well allowing them
to play allowing them to make mistakes
because that's what young players and
young teams will do but most importantly
Theodore holding them accountable if you
look at the pressers of Luke after games
is that ok we're young and we made men
oh no you know we did this wrong and we
have to get better and he calls out
names and you know it just goes back to
the old thing I say about Pat Riley and
why he's one of my all-time favorite
players our favorite coaches good and
great players want to be coached and
they want to be coached hard that's the
truth no one wants an easy route and
that's why he's been Pat Riley has been
one of the great coaches of all times
and I think that's why Luke Walton is on
his way to being a good coach 25 years
ago yesterday
Magic Johnson had his press conference
where he announced that he was
hiv-positive do you remember where you
were yeah i was in indiana and to me you
talked about the sky falling because as
you know magic was a mentor when i was
at UCLA we looked up to magic and you
know at the time you know early 90s you
know the education of HIV and AIDS it
wasn't as extensive as it is now you
know we didn't know we you know we
thought it was a death sentence so here
I am thinking you know my hero my idol
you know the guy my mentor that I looked
up to you know that the days were
numbered and 25 years later the smile is
even bigger and what he's done for the
african-american community and you know
to be a part time owner of the Dodgers
and a fantastic businessman it's
interesting because you know when I was
fortunate to go into the Hall of Fame
you know my first three calls obviously
I called my dad I called Cheryl but the
third person I had to call magic because
I wanted him to walk me into the hall
because that's how much he meant to me
know yeah i thought the day i thought
the sky was falling I thought it was a
death sentence as well but I'm just so
happy seriously because that's how much
admiration I have for buck I call him
buck for magic but you played when your
UCLA where you playing pickup games with
the Lakers the absolute I I will always
remember the best pickup games in the
world during the summer back in the mid
80s because you have the Lakers team
magic Cooper Byron the cream will come
up Kurt AC group that although are you
feeling that you had a team full of
froze Isaiah marker guayre Kiki
Vandeweghe Michael Jordan would come
through Larry came through a couple
times and then you would have like a MV
dl team so we had four teams we just
played round-robin on two courts and you
talk about the best basketball
unscripted now
to call fouls on everything and they
always want but just to be able to
witness it as a 18 19 20 year-old kid it
was the best basketball education I mean
every day from 2 to about 4 30 and then
before in the mornings we would work out
on Drake Stadium like at eight to about
ten run the stadium run the stairs to
push up pull ups and then move a go for
it was the best I mean learning
basketball from those guys I mean magic
and Cooper they taught me how to be
ruthless how to be it was great it was
absolute best Theodore who is the best
playground guy you played again because
there's always those guys who are just
great playing as a pickup guy they just
can't it doesn't translate to playing
organized basketball funny i'm gonna
give you one name and i want to see if
you can remember this because he didn't
have a great pro career but you he was
okay in college but you talk about the
summer league do you remember the swing
man from syracuse his name was i believe
it was Stevie Thompson Steve Thompson
from Los Angeles picked from LA yeah
during the summer he was like Michael
Jordan you could not stop this to you
well he dumped all the time oh my god he
was and he had a yeah pretty good career
at Syracuse but it just could not
translate at the next level but i think
he was there was likely in sherman
douglas yes yes exactly 71 to this guy
but great summer players in that
translate at the next level wait was he
Harold minor I'm not gonna go there well
we're not gonna yeah yes in the same
class yes okay at least Harold minor won
the slam dunk competition right yeah
yeah he was supposed to be member he was
maybe Jordan do you oppose me baby no
you don't want that nickname no no no
you don't want that no you don't know
you know reg will have the Sacramento
Kings against my Lakers coming up
thursday night at ten thirty eastern on
tnt alois like how you've just adopted
the lakers now yeah they're good they're
fun now they are they're fun to watch
yeah and that's all I'm asking okay so
here's our case in point and we can talk
about this next Tuesday okay going on
the road vs sacramento this this is a
good test for a young team they should
either be in the game and make it close
I don't care if they win or lose but
don't go up there and get blown out
you've got to grow each game you'd be
golden State you've beaten Houston you
beaten Atlanta on the road show maturity
go to Sacramento and compete don't go
there and lay an egg no that'll let me
know if they if they're amateur team or
not it's kevin durant at the front door
i hear the dogs barking yeah he is I'm
gonna go let him in my watch dogs at
their finest Thank You reg you're the
best you know I Reggie Aloysius Miller
Jr the third the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience